here's a chart share of adults 18 to 55
essentially you know from adult hood to
um
you know before you're older
who are currently married by class
so the highest are the upper middle
class 60
um
the working class 40 percent and the
poorest people out there
20 are married how are you processing
this the wealthier you are the more
reason is to get married the less poor
the less money you have less reason to
get married i saw this chart and i said
there's something here but that's why i
got smart experts on to maybe weigh in
on this you said
don't get married if you're trying to
play around are poor people just playing
around more
no you've have upper middle people
playing around too so but i i think um
you know when's the last time we had a
president united states that was single
i think i think it's uh buchanan yeah
buchanan or garfield i don't know we've
been hard working we've grown a long
time yeah what uh what uh
what president do we trust what
politicians do we trust what uh
personality do we trust that isn't uh
married i think if you're if you're
leading people
and uh and usually people in the upper
middle class income range they're
leading people leading
churches and non-profits and
corporations et cetera they're leading
their community i think a lot i'm trying
to process it myself too as well but i
think a lot of people relate to those
more that have
single married raised family more than
somebody that just you know 50 year old
single person six year old single person
that's out there oh look at the taxes
the second thing would be tax system tax
system incentivizes people to get
married
and it affects you when you are upper
middle class income
so so that if you for example real
estate if you were single and you sold a
piece of real estate your home residence
anything less than 250 is no capital
gain if you're married though five
hundred thousand dollars no capital gain
so like there's a business decision
questionable business ethics if you give
a shout out to uh
billy madison uh do you see yourself
getting married uh
no ever
no how old you derek i'm 30. 30.
when you were 30 did you see yourself
getting you know having the relationship
you had with you having kids right if i
see myself having kids yeah yeah i see
myself having kids but that's not the
kids not not married
i i was thinking that way too as well
until i realized the value of a woman in
the household because it was so tough
for me to be a single father with three
kids and i didn't have a mothering side
i didn't know how to mother my kids i
think that's why i i tell my kids today
i apologize for my sins i just didn't
know how to mother and you got to deal
with that for the rest of your life
you didn't know how to mother i didn't
know the mother
i just know i'd be a father marine
entrepreneur go out there get out of it
i didn't i i
there's many times i can remember
brother where i wish i just listened to
my kids more instead just tell me what
to do i was an [ __ ] i was an [ __ ]
with a single dad it hit points when he
came uh push push came to shove
and uh i had to learn from that and i
told myself let my 30s
the entire my entire thirties adam
repaid for mistakes in my 20s i should
be experiencing today at 48 at 38 but
because i wasn't getting my
my values and principles together that
was a tough because there is a value
between having a husband and a wife
mother and a father in a household
raising
a child i mean look who's going in
society today
i mean how many because of single
parenthood
it's destroyed the fabric of the
american unit and we have more kids that
are disrespecting authority having daddy
issues having mother issues the mental
condition of people today is a result of
husband and wife father mother not and
by the way co-parenting doesn't in my
opinion it doesn't work co-parenting
does not work in terms of your divorce
why because you're always competing with
your freaking ex
right i do it this way i'm down house
i'm doing this way no it should be based
on the kids
and how it's best for the kids not
between my house and your house and
again i'm learning through my mistakes
so please don't judge me i'm just
telling you what i screwed up with dude
i love you bro the the
i was going to ask you a formal question
you kind of just answered it but i
wanted to get your advice
again a lot of young entrepreneurs out
there mostly men
in their 20s 30s
getting married
certainly starting to have kids
uh what's the biggest piece of advice
you would have to young fathers out
there um you know
no big mistakes for the next 20 years
don't don't no duis don't get thrown in
jail
don't if you're going to sleep with a
woman in your mind i'm going to spend
the rest of my life with her
because she's going to get pregnant and
that's what you have to do for at least
for the next 18 20 years
you're 20 years old right now having sex
with her
be
and have her in all your plans for the
next 20 years
good or bad she's going to be there if
you have a kid with her and you destroy
a child by having sex with the wrong
woman you have a baby with the wrong
woman
uh from from an economic standpoint you
know uh find a woman that uh
is bought into um i think in today's day
and age i think uh i got less away from
hey baby i'm gonna be home at five
o'clock i'm not that guy i'm gonna go
out there and chase my dream and do my
thing and if she has an issue with that
then they may not be your wife because
you're gonna have conflict of chasing
your dreams your goals or your wife one
of them is going to get in the way and
the influence on me saying that uh you
know young man being in my 30s on me not
getting married it's just i've seen too
much guys
get destroyed
with marriage yeah but you can't let
their experience detect i don't have to
let their i could look at the data
i could look at data and and see and
shows like wow i mean women are being
incentivized
in in in when they have divorces
i mean when that when it is true when
they when they're when they're having
custody battles like women are being
incentivized for this and i've seen
every single month i've seen many guys
in the military yeah why you have to
pick a very good woman right so it
really goes back to you who is it that
you are going to pick to either have
kids with or you know because even if
you don't get married you know you have
to really careful with the type of woman
that you want to have around right so am
i supposed to just pick the good woman
and just completely ignore statistics
and data what a statistic got to do with
you though you can be the change to the
statistics that got nothing to do with
you you don't you don't live your life
how other people are living their life
you live your life how you want to live
your life and uh if you are
i don't know
you go get it however you want it to be
and this is how your children are going
to be raised as well like i can't think
here and say oh my gosh a lot of people
are getting a lot of shooting schools
are happening and i'm not going to have
children of course i'm going to learn
you can learn of course you can take the
data and you can take the data into
statistics and say hey
maybe marriage is
something that's that i shouldn't do or
maybe or maybe marriage is something
that i should
be more strategic on because a lot a lot
of times when people get married they're
i'm in love i'm going to get married
emotionally this is it
a dubs and flowers and everything
instead of sitting back and thinking all
right cool
what happened to my uncle when he got
married how is that going
dad
how come
you've been divorced and whatnot but how
were they raised what was their life
just asking just asking around and
where were they at in life because what
if you're in a different point where
you're successful and you have a good
place and you have a good mindset
but maybe your uncle he lived a life of
you know tragedy and things were going
exactly so for him his decisions were
based on those things going wrong and
you live a life of maybe those things
aren't going wrong i would say because i
i have a kid i've had kids since 1995.
when i was 22 years old had my first kid
and and i just had a kid at 45 years old
44 years old i'll tell you this there's
a much different aspect of raising
children having kids when things are
financially set you're more in an
emotional mature state because now
there's baby jordan he's got everything
i have to manage expectations with the
older kids don't get jealous of him
because he's going to have a lot more
going for him than you that you had when
he was his age
but i mean i met china at 38. i was 30
years old when i met china 10 years ago
wow so there's a different evolution of
version of me yeah that's what i'm
saying us the children need to teach our
grandparents and our fathers and our
uncles because they didn't know any
better right like we're the ones who
know and this is i honestly feel i'm
seeing the difference with my parents as
well how much they're learning and how
much they are just now admitting that
they're learning because before they
were just like you know the albanian
parents no i'm right no you're not gonna
do this because i said so like
very not healthy you know so let's leave
it right there i feel like we could do a
round two here no problem
we're almost at two hours and some
drinks in a cigar yeah
by the way we're gonna need a note to
the producers carpet table drinks moving
forward we need that right here eric if
you hear me this is what we're gonna
need from now on anyway
budget on sauce cast just went up a
little bit
cocktails drinks carpet rug table our
friend derek needs a cocktail uh and
matt needs a cigar and i'll bring a uh
uncle near his bottle whiskey
can i get an acknowledgement from the
producers that they heard that yes
yes i got you yes
there it was time for an upgrade
[Music]